the fight for the white house playing
out in must-win battleground states
today
president trump heading to wisconsin for
what looks to be a big rally
and joe biden's trying to win over
voters in pennsylvania
lately the democratic nominee has been
courting americans in the middle
politically
telling them he's a moderate but
progressives in the party want biden to
be
more liberal senator bernie sanders
warning biden
that he has to do more to excite
progressives and congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez saying this
i think overall um
we can likely push vice president biden
in a more progressive
direction across policy issues i think
foreign policy is an enormous area where
we can improve
immigration is another one criminal
justice
is is another area where where we can
pursue
a lot of progressive direction you know
there are some areas where we just
fundamentally disagree but that's okay
as election day near some democrats are
having deja vu
biden supporters in michigan say the
campaign nearly
invisible in that state and political
reporting quote
dems fear wisconsin governor is becoming
a liability for biden after his response
to unrest
in kenosha so jesse i wanted to start
off by just saying
sanders michael moore aoc
they all want biden to stir populist
energy
but wouldn't that risk biden losing
moderate support that
has him right now achieving the number
one goal of democrats
beating donald trump he'll do whatever
they tell him to do the election is very
funny when you think about it
you have very stark choices president
trump
is someone that cannot be controlled
he's out of control and that's what
drives so many people crazy his advisors
can't control
him his lawyers definitely can't control
the deep state
they tried to control him i mean he
doesn't do what people tell him to do he
marches to the beat of his own drum
contrast that with joe biden joe biden
is totally
controlled he has his advisors putting
scripts in his teleprompter they tell
him to stay in the basement he does it
his vp controls him you know now it's
the harris spied administration
aoc controls him bernie controls him
he'll do whatever barack obama says when
he calls him on the phone at 1600
pennsylvania
so it's basically like someone who's
can't be controlled versus someone
who is totally controlled a leader
versus a follower and if you look at joe
biden's policies since he got into this
race he's gone
far left on immigration guns taxes in
the climate
and now aoc say he's going to get pushed
around on foreign policy where exactly
i mean donald trump killed terrorists
cut peace deals
and brought our troops home where
exactly does aoc want to push him
it's basically another change election
donald trump
remains the agent of change and biden
wants to go back to the failed radical
policies that got us into the mess
in the first place and dan scavino said
something very interesting at the rnc he
said
they say it's chaos but president trump
calls it change and that's what's going
on here because he's forged new paths
for trade for immigration and for
foreign policy and there's a lot of
resistance to that change
in the country in the democratic party
and within the administrative state so
there's that clash but the people behind
donald trump
want that change they're fighting for
something because it's a movement
and that's why they're so much more
enthusiastic than joe biden's supporters
well dana to jesse's point biden's made
it pretty clear he
doesn't support defund the police he
doesn't support the green new deal he
doesn't support
medicare for all and i was thinking if
he did support these things
wouldn't it make him an easier target
for donald trump's claims that he's a
socialist
or you know trump has a new ad about uh
biden being weak on china
wouldn't that just open the gate to
trump attacks
well i think i think jesse makes a lot
of good points and i believe that aoc is
a
little bit more of a good she's probably
a better strategist than people give her
credit for
because what she just did there was to
subtly reassure
people that are in her sort of wing of
the camp
that don't worry everything's going to
be fine but that leaves
biden and kamala harris then to be out
there saying other things
and especially there in pennsylvania i
do think that
joe biden comes across as somebody who
can be pushed around partly because
he's not very forceful he's not forceful
when he talks about
the positions that he would take and
when he does try to be forceful he
almost sounds angry
so i think when you look um to the
debate which will be
is that just like it's only like less
than it's about 10 days away
um if one of the things president trump
can do is to get biden to react
angrily that will be probably uh
something
like a point in president trump's favor
in that debate because
something that biden does he'll say i
can't be pushed around
okay but you say you're going to support
this some of the budgets he's supporting
are very much
in line with more progressive thinking
and it just reminds me of one other
thing
i worked for a congressman in 1995. so
if you remember the
republicans sweep not only congress but
all across the country in 1994.
in 1995 the congressman i worked for had
been there for about 12 years
all of a sudden in one of the articles
it says that he they call him a moderate
and he came to my desk and he wanted a
correction he said
how did i become a moderate i'm a
conservative
and i said i think it's just because
when other people came in they said that
they were more conservative
than you so then everything moves along
i think for biden
he is more progressive than he was even
five years ago
greg i'm just thinking about recent
political history obviously lots of
democrats
were moderates who won in 2018 in the
midterms
and when i think about bernie sanders i
think gee
he lost the nomination battle twice
because most democrats
are either moderates or conservatives
so why should biden listen
to aoc or bernie at this late date
well because bernie was exciting
people wanted to vote for him no one
really wants to
vote for joe biden they just don't want
to vote for trump those are the people
who are
supporting biden right they just don't
want to vote for trump
so joe has to do more to excite the
progressives
but what more could they want i mean do
you want to have more
riots more looting more arson less
police
you want to bail out more rapists and
murderers you want to tear down more
statues elevate more criminals
reintroduce segregation to campuses
destroy the classroom with critical race
theory
ban more speech cancel more uh careers
accuse more people of racism and america
of oppression
uh take all the fun out of sports
destroy biology and gender
obliterate pronouns it seems to me in
the last 30 years
progressives have already gotten a hell
of a lot
so why give them more
hmm do you like my shirt oh okay well
that was interesting
yeah i was going to ask you about this
but wait
did you did you make that did you make
that shirt or did lou give it to you
yeah i left it at my apartment
oh my gosh that reminds me of a joke but
i i won't tell it
emily emily i i'm thinking to myself
that
president obama recently said democrats
should not form
a circular firing squad and it seems to
me like when you have
bernie sanders alexander ocasio-cortez
going after
uh the nominee joe biden it looks like
that circular frying squad's taking
shape
well that's interesting i see them as
almost the
volturi at this point coaching him along
and pushing him along
in the vessel that he is to me he's like
he's clearly changed from his days of
the obama administration but he's like
the emperor's new clothes
in that he keeps using his long-term
memory to spout these talking points
from that era but his actual policies
that he's putting forth
a shows the success of that valtteri and
b
shows that he's actually undercutting
the people in the industries that he's
professing to support so let me make two
examples really quickly
biofuels and fracking so with biofuels
he says he claims that he's a stronger
supporter of iowa farmers than the
president
but he supports boosting electric
vehicles that would
decimate corn and ethanol production out
of iowa and
eliminate natural and electric fuels or
natural fuels
industry and so i see that as having a
devastating effect on those small
farm family farms in iowa and then
fracking we know that he let slip in
that debate
with bernie that he was against it and
then he flew to pittsburgh
to assure the voters oh i didn't mean it
but remember his policy is power
generation fully renewable 100 by 2035
where does that leave the demand for
natural gas